jungs weise zu trinken und wir schauen
leide habe ziemlich oft getroffen
weitergehen mit seine
man schaut dann schreckliche wie sehr
kalkulieren verschiedene
in europa so lange dauert präsident
die willkommene information von allen
waffen wir brauchen nicht nur bestätigen
diesem dass das teil von von einem land
ist zeigt erneut wie schwierig es ist
herr melnik hat schon in diesem
unserer stadt passiert dass leute kommen
was mit
auch nach kiel feierte vor ort unser
kranke vision dass es im pda aufzubauen
viele russische medien was ist ziemlich
selensky hat das ja auch scharf
zurückbringen
sogar schlimmeres szenario
zivilisten was ich nicht einfach
muss kann es nie gut gehen wenn in dem
waffen schwer die lieferung schnell
kritisiert werden gleichzeitig in den
acht filmen und sie ist ziemlich
thomas wir haben ja in der letzten woche
und beteiligungs waffen verteidigen das
zum ein herz doch dahinter steht eine
kann ich mir jetzt hast du in
bis heute ist heutige zeit so genannte
reporter paul ronzheimer wie immer paul
austausch
und die war ein zählung bleibt ein ziel
menschen die können nicht mehr
nächsten tagen die offensive im osten
hier der preis also hältst du den
lange zeit in deutschland
land in unserem land in unsere heimat
irgendwie entscheiden am anfang des
diesen scharfen streit und wie von bild
genau gezeigt wird das alles heck und
deutschland viele gespräche geführt
wäre nicht nur unsere stadt nicht nur
nervös sind auch viele was eine mögliche
gearbeitet und es gibt in
noch größer werden kann also eine neue
dass die russischen truppen sich für
krieg herrscht ausdauer ist angesagt
punkte und versteht es
entspannen eine urlaub machen seine
enthüllte ausladung von frank walter
genau über dieses thema waffen schwere
und
krieges in dem interview hast du mir mal
einsatz von taktischen atomwaffen für
riesige schlange glaube ich paar tausend
ich meine damit gibt es auch einen
möglich ich hoffe ich nicht aber ich
eine offensive gegen den bon bars neu
unsere land und wurde in deutschland um
offensive gegen städte und dörfer durch
gesagt dass dein sohn geschrieben hat
wird propaganda das wirkt dann sehr
steinmeier lebt das hat natürlich dazu
gewissen grund man kann darüber
ich bin fest überzeugt sie sehen gesehen
atomare bedrohung angeht aus russland
waffen jetzt sind ein paar wochen
diskutieren
per sms papa pass auf dich auf als es so
kinder sehen weil die
ausdauer
geführt dass die diskussionen auch hier
leute stehen
aufstellen bedeutet also offenbar nicht
schließe ich nicht aus lade mir wie ist
vergangen und weiterhin sind keine
verschiedenen gründen aber leidet
ich bin fest überzeugt durch sagt komm
aber fakten sie den fakten und von den
politik in deutschland muss verstehen
ganzen tag nur eine marke kaufen marke
also längst die luft nicht nur
wie virus und nennen sich
deine einschätzung
schweren waffen hier
in der ukraine wieder immens geworden
präsident so lenski hat gesagt dass er
heftig war etwas was sie jetzt was sagen
zur schaltung die schwere waffen zu
sind dort schon
dass andere städte sich derweil in
wir verteidigen auch deutschland weil
problematik ist verstimmt gibt noch
kann halt gedacht dass russland
emotionale sondern viele andere sachen
fakten kann man nicht irgendwie weg
sind und immer wieder natürlich davon
sicherheit wiegen können
den einsatz von taktischen atomwaffen
deine kinder genauso gleich die sind
liefern aber das müssen wir beim ead
während geben sie keine richtige antwort
laufen deswegen diese diskussion
deswegen deswegen
jugendgerecht
wenn wir jetzt hier auf den platz
die sünde krieges sie hinter krieges
ich werde mich noch dran wo ich wieder
für möglich hält seht ihr das auch so
betroffen das gemüse lenski unter
nein thomas vladimir putin der russische
und deswegen bleiben wir so lange im
groß die
briefmarke briefmarke wo
schauen da hinten sind noch ein paar
diese wartezeit wird mehr mittelmäßige
genauso wie keine kann es fest sie davon
zwischen gabriel und wenig es hat ein
wenn zeigen wir 10
schreiben gerufen haben beständig die
jetzt leider kann ich denke die
barrikaden aufgebaut man sieht sagt jack
nach die schreckliche bilder gott sei
unsere wunsch ein teil von europäische
anderem immer wieder klar macht dass er
diktator will offenbar ihr auch diesen
steht der russische schiff geht weit weg
leben teilen das ist die durch die
an die konsequenz die versprochene
nicht zufrieden ist mit dem was
point wann wird kiew wieder die stadt
weiter wird uns angreifen kann ich mir
gewissen grund und letztendlich diese
familie zu sein eine demokratische land
dank
vermisste
sichern dass die atomwaffen nicht
einsatz bis frieden wieder hier im lande
psychoterror die ständige angst der
deutschland bislang geliefert hat und
kinder familie aber dann wurde
die wir kennen aus der vergangenheit vor
hier hingegen kommt sofort kamen
grund ist diese krieg was hier in der
konsequenzen will chemie in den
verwendet werden mann oder wir in der
politik
so aufzubauen und jungs ab ganz andere
das deutsche regierungspolitiker
von buchrain das ist eine symbolische
menschen weiter befeuern indem er
begreifen dass nachdem eine große
viele leute in deutschland fragen sich
ukraine herrscht aber es ist nicht
berichte waren völlig informationen was
dem krieg ist nur viel viel zu früh zu
herrscht
insbesondere olaf scholz nicht bereits
ukraine rechnen mit allen an alles was
versionen der ukraine macht
raketen richtung lemberg schickt in dem
und das wird kommen wissen nicht wann
ihr seid jetzt seit fast zwei monaten
absurd dass dann gerade die spd den
briefmarke leute wollen das haben dass
verluste und eine große gefahr für durch
und
vision die sowjetische reich wieder auf
sagen
passiert zum beispiel in boutiquen
in schwere waffen zu liefern also man
hier seite an seite zusammen wie wie
diese schien mit konsequenzen nehmen wir
zum normales leben kommen wir denke ich
er hier auch in kiew raketen alarm
noch auf uns zukommen wird kann auch
ukrainischen botschafter zur jetzigen
das wird kommen und
reine oder hiob dass man muss schnell
zur warnung deutschland muss deutsche
hat schon das gefühl hier in der ukraine
es gibt
auslöst auch gestern sind wieder
zeit so anders
immer in hauptplatz passiert
das insgesamt dieser streit tatsächlich
bewegung stellen wir das komme aber
geht es euch persönlich und wann kannst
mal in nächsten monate noch nicht weil
muss niemals vergessen weil von goisern
mit unserem leben natürlich deutschland
menschen hier gestorben man hat das muss
schlimme folgen haben also wir rechnen
mariupol ivo ist ganz klar ganze stadt
wir wissen dass ich möchte nicht tief in
entscheiden
müssen am menschen denken an unsere
ehemalige dass er allein war ein teil
du mal wieder nach deutschland zu deiner
man unseren zuschauern erklären zwar
etwas besonderes außergewöhnlich ist
dafür sorgen kann dass die beziehung
mit allem
das ist die bezahlung der trio die
unterstützt an und hat uns unterstützt
ist mir heute schon für das leben
ein ende ich hoffe nun dass es ende des
sie rechne mit allem und paul du hast
durch den teilabzug diese ständige
zerstört und die hälfte von der stadt
stadt in euroland und alles vom wasser
die politik in deutschland gehen aber
familie dann könnt ihr dann kannst du
von so richtig rein wie geht ihr damit
dauerhaft belastet werden insbesondere
dass seine symbolische platz bleib ich
und heike zerstörte genau das gleiche
gefahr der einkesselung gebannt aber was
gekommen ist
deine kinder wieder sehen
die klitschkos dann auch noch zu den
seit 2004 10 seit der revolution hier
wichtigste preis
letztendlich ist wird er immer war
krieges schnelle kommt als langsam
wenn jetzt im osten diese offensive
schlimmere situation in die riege vor wo
trinken fonds machen schnell wie möglich
wie ist die situation wenn ich die
um dass deutsche politiker weiterhin
bitteren streit befragte der zwischen
man nicht gebannt hat thomas ist die
zwei briten von bevölkerung von gf
wie wird es in der ukraine weiter gehen
unterstützend für diese freundliche
mir wenn du von hier jetzt dorthin
vitali wie geht es dir damit dass du
losgeht und russland dort erfolgreich
sagen keine schweren waffen
dem ehemaligen deutschen außenminister
diese sinnlose krieg zu beenden und von
tatsache dass raketen immer das ganze
und
gibt keine journalisten aber dort ist
bilder im kopf wieder abrufen das was
aus deiner sicht wenn du auf den osten
politik gegen russland und das wissen
deine kinder schon so lange nicht sehen
schaust in den osten nach mario pohl
sigmar gabriel und dem ukrainischen
anwohner schon im tief
jetzt diese kritische zeiten wo wirklich
land treffen können das heißt nirgendwo
konnte dass es für dich auch unmöglich
eine richtige minister katastrophe
sein würde als die in kiew und dann wird
botschafter in deutschland andré melnik
ihr mutiges trieb ihn gesehen haben denn
deutschen dass auch erkennt und deswegen
schaust du gehst du davon aus dass die
trotzdem ich hier
der mit
überall dort wo der schlimme krieg
in der ukraine
ist sozusagen rauszukommen aus kiel
vielen verschiedenen wegen und mitteln
es ist nicht mit fäusten des trans
ausgebrochen ist und denen die beiden
zivilisten sind gestorben was nach
großoffensive in der nächsten woche
nirgendwo sind die menschen wirklich
das ist für immer war ein bisschen zu
gerade öffentlich über zeitungsartikel
in chile an ihre bürger noch nicht zu
startet
ich noch einmal bedanken sun alle war
herrscht was geht hier vor
man natürlich erneut nach schuldigen
inklusive geherrscht und es ist
sicher deswegen wird auch vor einer
verteidigen man braucht auch mittel und
und twitter botschaften austragen wir
ich habe mich als ein team kabul
suchen und wird immer wieder sagen
rückkehr zum beispiel hier nach kiew
solche schreckliche bilder
man versteht wie sein kann und wie es
spät das ist die jeden
deutschland hat nicht genug geliefert
kein schlimmer kriegen sondern
hat seine pläne und will seine pläne
braucht auch waffen um sie zu
letztendlich bekannt und liegt
gewarnt trotzdem hast du heute dort in
und bericht war und glaube so
erklären das noch mal kurz bevor wir die
zusammen mit rainer steht und an alle
allen zurückzukommen weil heute gästen
getroffen er kann nicht mehr in sein
verteidigen und frieden wieder dazu
tag wie jede stunde zählt am menschen
kriegsverbrechen
auch wenn es vielleicht ein bisschen
ist das land ist ein teil von uns in
antworten dann hören gabriel wirft
stellen wir klar dass die noch nie da
trotzdem realisieren wo keine zu
von wem wie sollten wir abhängt die
unfair ist wenn man auf andere länder
kiew am hellichten tag auf dem majdan
tageslicht
leben seine eltern sehen weil er eltern
passiert wenn das land vor allem jetzt
waren griffen favorit also seine
nämlich im spiegel verschwörungstheorien
wie frankreich oder italien schaut das
ich
das
sie und das ist immer ich sage mal
paul also auf diesen symbolträchtigen
kopieren die tief hauptstadt war ein
kreativen stadt umgeht
vorbei der behaupte bundespräsident
sind gedeutet als relativ ums leben wenn
leben
hoffe nur noch mal man wird nicht aktiv
in ruggell menschen haben kein wasser
ist ja eher eine europäische ein
und
enttäuschend man will natürlich mehr
frank walter steinmeier der gerade in
platz in kiew mit den klitschko-brüdern
europäisches problem mit ausnahmen in
vorgestern war ein tief eine luftangriff
kein
in die politik gehen in deutschland
kiew nicht empfangen wurde habe in
ziel und bleibt ein ziel und das ist
essen keine
osteuropa aber deutschland ist hier zum
das ist richtig dass es wichtig für uns
seiner aktiven zeit als politiker seit
aber ich möchte das nicht einseitig
sprechen können
angriff heute fünf menschen gestorben
wichtig ist dass deutschland durch
möglichkeit aus dem keller raus zu
jahrzehnten ein spinnennetz der kontakte
symbol des nicht helfen es geworden egal
dass es richtig und so an dass es
machen letztendlich deutschland versucht
gegen russland nicht alle gesetze alle
thomas das war eine ganz besondere
unterstützt um sie mit einer front
mit russland geknüpft dazu schreibt
wichtig für europa wieder früh wieder
deswegen die risiko ist noch da und gibt
kommen weil die werden ständig
ich möchte nie wieder deutschland nicht
wie fair oder unfair diese bewertung ist
gegenüber stehen dass diese krieg
gabriel dann auf den punkt gebracht in
szenerie muss man sagen vielleicht auch
bombardiert
im schutz zu nehmen oder gut reden und
die nähe dieser vergleicht das der
alle werte alle menschlichen der einfach
und 20 uhr wird der ukrainische
zur erklärung das ist ja der platz wo
es noch überhaupt sinnvoll und auch
frieden wieder ruhige zeiten
oder wenn hier aus sind dann können die
frühere kanzleramtes und außenminister
beendet wird mit jedem mittel dass der
botschafter andrej melik dann hier bei
alles begann 2014 die revolution damals
das schönreden das gut erklärt
die interessenvertretung russlands in
im kugelhagel sterben
draußen
uns in der sendung seinen vielen dank
frieden wieder da in der ukraine
verständnis was betrifft moderne welt
langsam alles kommt in unsere stadt und
deutschland mit organisiert habe das ist
wir brauchen das wir brauchen das jetzt
schon vitali klitschko der dort immer an
es ist unglaublich was
nach kiew vielen dank an dich paul
stattfinden wird wieder die du hast
vorderster front war damals der
wahrheitswidrig und
glaube ich hoffe dass es wirklich kommt
viele spd-politiker auch kennengelernt
und wieder menschen zu sterben und die
hoffen wir bald computing grund mit
in der eu politik gerade macht es ist
oppositionsführer gab spekulationen er
bösartig der konter von melnik kommt
viele politiker verschiedener
frühling kommt auch friesen hoffen wir
koalitionen in den letzten jahren hat
könnte sogar präsident werden und er
nicht mehr würden zu beschreiben es ist
und zwar nicht in wochentakt
dann via twitter das schauen wir uns
stand dort mit hunderttausenden die dann
deutschland ein putin problem hat die
eine pure kriegsverbrechen zerstörung
zahl von menschen 1000 aus und wir
vielen dank vitali klitschko vielen dank
auch noch mal an bösartig ist vor allem
spd ein putin problem war man zu
dafür gesorgt haben dass janukowitsch am
wissen nicht genau das ist zehn zwanzig
von existenz was passiert war den rippen
ich mit klitschko alles gute und
freundlich gegenüber russland sollte so
stunde wie erklärte dass vitali dass das
ihre sigmar gabriel und ihrer spd
ende geflohen ist und ich habe vitali
hoffen wir alle dass der frieden schnell
klitschko und wladimir klitschko heute
kumpane jahrelange putin freundliche
30.000 wie viel um wie viel durch eine
gleichzeitig hat man das gefühl
im bild interview gefragt wie fühlt sich
kommt
deutschland feiert ostern
ja mit frühling kommt auch wieder schön
politik gewesen die diesen barbarischen
muss noch sterben bis zum eine bestimmte
das an jetzt auf dem leiter einzustellen
vernichtungskrieg gegen die ukrainischen
versucht so ein bisschen abzuschalten
zeit schwere waffen geliefert
wäre dass paul sag mir wie sehr belastet
staat die ukrainische nation die
für ein herz für unsere stadt für unser
auf fast von dem was hier vorgeht und
gehst du davon aus dass auch kiew wieder
ukrainische kultur gegen ukrainische
immer noch sind keine schweren waffen in
dieser streit zwischen gabriel der ja in
frauen und kinder erst herbeigeführt hat
land alles was in
der ukraine mit dem titel aus
angegriffen werden könnte wir
erst herbeigeführt hat die aufarbeitung
der spd ist also in der aktuellen
deutschland zumindest wir brauchen
kanzlerpartei und dem ukrainischen
kommt noch shame on you also schämen sie
botschafter in deutschland melnik das
sich wir haben nochmal rein paul was
deutsch ukrainische verhältnisse
generell im moment
dann die klitschko brüder auf diese
vorwürfe gesagt haben während herzlicher
sowohl für die ukraine als auch für
deutschland schlecht ich glaube dass
[Musik]
[Applaus]